[Music]
hi my name is crystal baby no no no life
is different now today we are doing
exactly what the title of this video
says what you think what the holidays
what do you think of merriment cheer
moaning I Google Image Search holiday
lingerie and I found some very sexy
holiday lingerie that I thought I could
make myself at home with what I had on
him this is essentially will it Keaney
but not at all challenge myself to
recreate two holiday lingerie looks
using only items I have in my house
currently let's do it when I google how
to church holiday lingerie a lot of like
sexy Santa's and sexy mrs. Claus
scenarios came up and then I saw this
girl she's a sexy lingerie snowman
nothing says me like 3d spheres of pure
ice let's make this look so she's got
basically a white mesh long-sleeve
bodysuit that I do not have if you have
that how was the race I'm gonna
piecemeal this together I do have so
many male wife beaters that haven't been
worn yet my house is a treasure trove of
trash so I'm gonna take a wife beater
and then cut it into a bodysuit and glue
the cooter area together let's start
sizing this is how fashion designers do
it but this can't happen in this area
Bam Bam Bam Bam
yeah just gonna let the cooter area dry
there for a second basic white body
suiters done it's nicely I don't have
long sleeves but I have long socks I
want to be able to use these after this
so I'm not gonna glue them to this
bodysuit instead I'm gonna use them as
beautiful tacky gloves next we need
those three buttons I have a bag of
pom-poms because what 30 to old woman
doesn't have a bag of pom-poms so I'm
gonna find a couple black pom-poms and
hot glue them to the front of them there
we go we have our button now we need the
green and red and white scarf with black
fringe so I'll just take another wife
beater let's do that I hate that there
I'll take another white tank-top jeez
is about as white as her scarf and this
is nice because this is shining light on
something that I don't think people talk
about one of the sexiest accessories
that you could wear in the bedroom is a
scarf we're gonna hot glue these
together beauty is in the eye of the
beholder welcome back my doge your owner
is busy creating art and forwarding her
career base of scarf done now let's draw
some green and red stripes on this yeah
it's got some black fringe at the end of
it I found just some black felt sheep
this is lingerie now our scarf has
fringe only on one side don't show the
backside that's how it is normally in
lingerie anyway the last bit is the Hat
which I just happen to have this laying
around my house this is a fourth of July
tiny hat but I don't feel like covering
it in black fabric to make it look like
the hat that she's wearing because I
might use this in the future and that's
why I have so much anger on my house so
I'm gonna keep this hat the way it is so
if you put all of these pieces that we
have di wide together this is the final
sexy snowman lingerie look
ah pretty impressive I know it couldn't
tell the difference and I mean you saved
like tens of dollars so you're welcome
on to the next look so the most popular
image that comes up when I Google Image
Search holiday lingerie was this one
this looks so uncomfortable but God
bless the girls modeling this for trying
to make it work she's a gift to the
world regardless we're gonna try and DIY
our own version of this here's an I'm
using this red bra that's totally fun
that I probably paid a decent amount of
money for but I don't wear to wear
sports bras because I've given up if you
have red satin ribbon obviously that
made it much easier thing to use for
this but I don't have that tried to find
any red fabric and I have two red aprons
let's just cut these aprons into some
strips of red fabric that we can use to
cover our landing strip no got the
longest parts first these aprons that
I'm working with right now are a canvas
like material which unlike satin is not
a material you ever probably want near
your cooter so that's fun I'm done all
right
oh whoa this might be interesting how do
you make a bow like that she's going to
be a bow on the boobs whether you want
to or not perfect that's more strips
good old-fashioned hot glue them
together hotsy-totsy we're gonna measure
it out good we're gonna glue this behind
our bow oh you can see it start to come
together we're gonna let the hot glue
set on our bow and then we are going to
fixate it to our bra and tuck the back
piece behind our bra straps so that the
final sexy and lingerie
holiday ribbon wrap outfit looks like
this
again almost identical and because I
used only items I have in my house I
saved literally $19.99 Wow
this has been a really successful DIY
holiday lingerie video if you liked it
give it a thumbs up let me know if you
want me to do more videos like this
before the end of the holiday season and
do not forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel i'm not necessarily
making videos monday wednesday and
friday this month instead i'm gonna try
and make them at my leisure when i have
ideas and feel excited about something
i'm going to try and recalibrate and
figure out exactly what my schedule will
be in january so make sure you're
subscribed anyway and hit that fill
notification so that you know when I
upload videos cuz right now it's a
little bit old place but by January we
will have it figured out I hope I've met
I don't you bow
be a bow be a goddamn bow you're
embarrassing us now that who wants to
shoot me